[Music]
welcome to the science podcast for
February 23rd 2018 I'm Sara Krusty in
this week's show David Grimm talks with
me live at the triple a s annual meeting
about painting sleuths combating
alternative facts and keeping birds from
flying into buildings news editor Tim
Appenzeller discusses the unexpected age
of some European cave paintings which is
causing experts to rethink the mental
capabilities of Neanderthals we also
have our monthly book segment with
Django Beck she interviews William e
Grassley about his book a wilder time
notes from a geologist at the edge of
the Greenland ice first up we have an
excerpt from a live podcast event at the
triple-a s annual meeting with me and
David Grimm talking artsleuth David
Grimm online news editor for science is
here with me at the triple a meeting in
Austin Dave's been beavering away and
he's brought one on high-tech art
sleuthing hi Dave
hi Sarah how are you good tell me about
this painting what are we learning about
it Sarah do you speak French
no good luck with this title yes is a
Picasso painting from 1902 and boy I
don't even know if I should try to
there's an English but the u.s. rent
rebate translation is the crouching
beggar it's basically this it's a
landscape scene it's a picture of a
woman crouching you can see a picture of
this on the site what's interesting
about this painting is we know that this
wasn't the original painting on the
canvas there was another Barcelona
artist that painted on this canvas
before Picasso took to it and actually
some of what this artist painted some
mountains and stuff
Picasso seems to have taken some
inspiration from that and that you know
the mountain sort of became a bit of the
outline of the woman that's really cool
too because if you look at the two
paintings on the site the under painting
the really old one the older one is
horizontal but
Picasso's is vertical it's really cool
right yeah and they've known about that
under painting for a long time right
1992 researchers used to x-ray
radiography to find out that there was a
painting behind the painting that there
was this landscape painting that another
artist had painted but in this new study
the researchers wanted to help even
deeper
what else is going on in this painting
what else is sort of hidden behind this
1902 Picasso painting cuz they saw
something they see some cracks and they
sort of deduce that something else is
going on behind ya and you know they had
already used the x-ray radiography in
the past so in this new study they used
a couple of new techniques what is
called hyperspectral infrared
reflectography and basically this
involves shining light of different
wavelengths on an object I was really
kind of cool is in certain wavelengths
pain as she becomes transparent so you
can actually see what's going on because
yeah and what this is the one where they
revealed what was kind of between these
two paintings right right basically what
they found with this technique was they
found another hidden layer of painting
that they hadn't discovered before and
in fact under the woman's cloak Picasso
seems to have painted an image of the
woman's hand clutching a piece of bread
now at some point he decided he didn't
want that because we don't see that in
the final painting most of the woman is
actually obscured by the cloak and what
the researcher says it gives us a really
interesting insight into what Picasso
sort of thinking at the time you know
he's like well maybe I should have a
woman doing something he originally
paints that and then for some reason his
sights no I don't want her actually
actively clutching anything doing it
with her hands of the painting let's
cover they don't think it was it
purposely hidden layer underneath the
top layer well I mean he did I mean
right he decided to paint over that he
didn't want that reflected now another
technique he used was something called
macro x-ray fluorescent imaging and this
really involves zapping the painting
with x-rays and what the researchers did
there was they saw they were able to see
the elements that make up the plane the
pain for example Picasso seems to have
used a lot of lead in his white paint
instance and this can give us a little
bit of insight into what was on his
palate and why he was choosing to maybe
use certain colors over others did any
of this reveal more about the under
painting - older painting us underneath
not really but now that the researchers
have these new techniques and these new
images they're really curious about this
underlying painting who was the artist
the pain of it why was it painted over
was the artist painting a night scene or
a scene all this stuff can actually be
potentially figured out with some of
these new techniques and actually one of
the researchers behind this has actually
traveled to Barcelona see if you can
figure out exactly what landscape was
being painted
originally we're on our second day of
live podcasting Dave and I discuss
communication in the era of fake news
and preventing birds from crashing into
tall objects david Grimm editor for our
online news site is here with me at the
triple-s
annual meeting in austin dave has some
more stories it's Sunday so things are
winding down hi Dave hey Sara so let's
talk about facts first alternative facts
yes regular facts
fake facts Ignis okay we've heard these
terms a lot and why do we have a session
on it well so the idea was you know
there's a lot of scientists out there
that are frustrated with this idea that
there could be more than one version of
the facts you know this was this term
alternative facts sort of became popular
when US President Donald Trump took
office and a lot of scientists want to
push back and they want to find out how
can we fight back against these
quote-unquote alternative facts and let
the public know that there's really only
one way there's only one fact there's a
falsehood yeah and how do we sort of
bring people more on that way of
thinking rather than just sort of trying
to dismiss anything they don't agree
with as false or as some sort of you
know alternative to the truth and this
is a session of news you can use so it
wasn't just panelists pointing to their
research their slides it was actually
like engaging with audience that's right
and answering questions about how you
can deal with this at Thanksgiving
dinner how you can deal with this when
you're talking to a group so what are
some of the tips that they shared well
so one of the one that just was appealed
to the 60% that's if the idea is that
you've got this group of people there's
gonna be a spectrum of beliefs and
there's gonna be 20% on each side that
are really dogging like a normal
distribution and so the idea is the
people that are really dug in on either
end of the spectrum it's it's a waste of
your time to try to convince them you
never think of in something right
there's this sixty percent in the middle
whose attitudes may be a bit more
malleable and those are the people you
should target and to get back to the
science part of this is something that
people have validated this is not just
conventional wisdom right right this is
I believe this has been sort of
empirically okay what are some of the
other tips they talked about one of the
other ideas is appeal to shared value
so you know what the speakers talked
about climate scientist named Catherine
deo who's an evangelical Christian and
the way she makes inroads with her
fellow evangelicals is to talk about
their shared real worldview and to sort
of use that as sort of a bridge to
talking about things like climate change
okay so don't just shout people down and
tell them things they don't want to hear
well and also just you look for things
you have in common I don't you know even
if you maybe maybe it's religion you
know politicians like to say you know
you and I both ride the train to work
every day so we have something in common
try to find those shared experiences so
that you're not coming in as sort of
this alien being that you know has all
these beliefs that are so foreign to
somebody else it's you know we have a
lot in common and facts can be something
we haven't here's how those fit in with
our worldview and what about this golden
child idea well this idea that you know
every group has a member that's very
admired potentially for podcasting so if
you can you know if you can convince the
golden child you may be able to convince
the rest of the group okay
let's also talk about this bird story
this is about preventing birds from
running into things are flying into
things very high in the air right do we
know why birds fly into tall objects
like wind turbines skyscrapers yes this
is a major problem millions of birds
slamming into buildings wind turbines
other structures every year one of the
reasons is that they don't their eyes
don't face forward when they're flying
and so they've got this huge blind spot
in front of them and so they're not
really paying attention to right what's
right in front of them obviously then we
have this problem where millions of
birds are potentially dying every year
because they're slamming into these
objects okay so they're they're looking
down that's kind of like texting and
driving
how do the researchers try to like test
out a method for getting them to pay
attention to where they're going
most of the idea is you know can we make
a sound it doesn't matter where they're
looking there should be able to hear a
loud sound and what that's research was
tried in this study they had 16 zebra
finches in a lab and they they have fly
through this corridor the birds fly
through this corridor so at the length
of a bus and sometimes they can fly all
the way through and sometimes they would
be caught in this mesh net and it's
actually not as bad as it sounded was
pretty gentle edge so the birds create
better
the skyscraper and what the researchers
found is when they played a loud noise
right before the birds were to strike
the net they tended to slow down and
then maybe looked around them a little
bit more and so the researchers say well
maybe something like an acoustic
lighthouse or something that would wear
a sound but they also think the sound
itself by itself may not be enough that
you may be up Lenny you might need to
combine the sound with something like a
flashing siren okay now like you know
the idea is that the sound might help
but it's not gonna be right and all be
all you may have to do some other things
maybe there are certain kinds of sounds
I don't work better that's true yeah so
this helps birds but it also helps us
right right yes so for example you know
we've had airplanes go down like the
famous of miracle nuts and there was a
bird strike this is not just good for
birds but if we can keep birds away from
objects we don't want them near it could
be good for us too okay
thanks Dave thanks sorry is there
anything else we should keep an eye out
for meeting news coming up yeah we've
got an interesting story about how
babies recover from strokes I didn't
even know babies got the infant's like
very very babies and this is very young
children that get strokes and how their
brains recover much better than they
recover when they're adults or then when
we're we're adults when we get strokes
especially older adults and also a story
about whether Americans are giving up on
science or whether the belief the
American belief in the scientific
enterprise is as strong as it's always
been so keep an eye on our meeting
coverage all right thanks Dan thanks sir
next week we'll have another excerpt
from the annual meeting an interview
with Michael Varnum on what people say
will happen if we make contact with
aliens stay tuned now for an interview
with science news editor Tim Appenzeller
he'll be discussing newly dated cave
paintings that suggest Neanderthals made
art
[Music]
this week two papers one in science and
one in science advances provide new
evidence that Neanderthals made art cave
paintings and painted shelves Tim
Appenzeller wrote a new story putting
these results together with what
researchers in the field used to think
about Neanderthal brains welcome Tim
thank you okay so we have audio only
here can you describe what these cave
paintings look like well they're simple
these are these are not Rembrandt's they
are a set of lines that look kind of
like a window frame the outline of a
hand a hand stencil and a painted cave
formation it's a drapery like formation
that has been painted reddish and where
were these found they are all in Spanish
caves they've been known for a long time
what wasn't known was how old they are
with the new technology they used a date
that's put it back before modern humans
were thought to be in Europe right when
when is the date the new date it varies
but yes modern humans were thought to
have arrived in Europe are thought to
have arrived in your 40 to 45 thousand
years ago and the dates for these
objects and paintings are much much
earlier so the paintings are all at
least sixty-four thousand years old and
the shells are at least 115 thousand
years old how did they get these new
dates I mean how do you date something
that's painted on rock which thing is
you know amenable to checking on yeah
well they don't date the painting itself
what they date is the crust of calcite
that forms over the paintings in some
caves providing the painting has some
flowing groundwater a thin crust of
calcite can be deposited on the painting
it's the same stuff that forms
stalagmites and stalactites right and so
if there's this layer over top of the
painting you know the painting is older
it has to be at least as old as the
layer and it could be thousands of years
older mm-hmm okay
so we have very exciting news for a lot
of people in this field and this kind of
a shock right they weren't expecting to
see art from Neanderthal hands no not at
always been a long argument it's gone on
for decades and decades about what
Neanderthals were sort of capable of
what their what their brains could do
right you know recently it's been clear
that they
were capable of more sophisticated
behavior and technology than had been
thought people have found things like
elaborate wooden Spears a glue that they
made from tree bark tree resin sorry for
hafting spear points out of spears a
couple of years ago some French cavers
found these weird constructions deep in
a French cave
they're basically big rings of broken
stalagmites and they're 300 meters into
the cave they weren't built for shelter
that's that's for sure they must have
been built for ritual purposes and those
two of those two have been dated to one
hundred and seventy-five thousand years
ago so so obviously things were going on
in the end with all mines they weren't
as different from us as had been thought
what were modern human the ancestors of
modern humans doing at these times were
they also painting things building
things designing things well they were
just elsewhere in in Africa and in the
Middle East yes they were creating shell
beads painting them and piercing them so
they could use them of body ornaments
they were engraving designs into into
ochre and into ostrich egg shells they
weren't painting caves so this really
raises the possibility or actually makes
it seem quite likely that the
Neanderthals were the first to go deep
into caves and paint the walls Wow all
right Tim so how are we ever gonna
resolve what it was like to be Indian
dirt all what their thinking was like
what their social life was like I mean
we have such tiny clue this is do you
see anything in the next few years that
might give us even more information well
they are tiny clues or they have been up
so now and it looked like this debate
was going to go on forever but this
discovery three different sets of
paintings are far too old have been made
to have been made by modern humans
really does push the ball forward quite
a lot and I think there's no reason to
think that we won't find equally
dramatic sort of things that change our
picture yet again in the coming years
okay thank you so much Tim Tim
Appenzeller is the news editor for
science he writes about Neandertal art
this week in the magazine you can find a
link to his article and the studies at
science bag org
podcasts next up we have Jen go back
she'll be talking with William Grassley
about his book a Wilder time notes from
a geologist at the edge of the Greenland
ice hi everyone I'm Jen gull Beck and
welcome to the February book segment
this month we're reading William Glass
Lee's a while their time notes from a
geologist at the edge of the Greenland
ice and this is a little different than
a lot of the books we cover because it's
not a straight up science book it's more
of a love letter to Greenland from a
scientist who worked there there is a
lot of interesting science in the book
but it's also this beautiful narrative
that shares the emotion that comes with
doing science something that we
scientists so often push aside to
objectively report the results of our
work
so William glass leaves joining me and
I'm hoping you can tell us what got you
to the place where you decided you
wanted to write a book that combines
science a very objective thing with your
very moving personal emotional
connection to Greenland started going to
Greenland several decades ago and I
never went there intending to write a
book I went there simply to do the
science that I was interested in at the
time although I really enjoyed
wilderness areas hiking camping being in
the wild doing geology I did not expect
the experience I had in Greenland to be
what turned out to be
it was transformative and the reason it
was was because when I went there to do
the science we were there for a month
completely isolated from the rest of the
world and had a chance to wander through
this huge wilderness area and I kept
thinking this is not what I expected the
opportunity to do very analytical
objective work in the field is a very
powerful and moving thing but being able
to do it in a setting that is as
stunningly beautiful and as wild as
Greenland was was a shock to me it
insinuated itself inside me in such a
way that I could not
once we came back from Greenland I could
not stop thinking about it and so I
started writing memories I jotted down
and I kept doing that for a period of
time trying to relive what had happened
we continued going back over the next 20
30 years every time we would go the
experience of place became more and more
powerful and I realized in the process
that this was as much doing about doing
science as as the science was can you
talk about that a little more because
this is something we don't get very much
of in science do you think it's
important for scientists to communicate
science in a way that shares that very
personal experience we have while we're
doing our work why do you think this
matters to us as scientists you know we
as scientists are representatives of the
human species we dedicate our lives to
learning things that we then share with
the rest of humanity and it's a way of
informing ourselves of the context of
our existence and it occurred to me that
it was not honest to keep from the rest
of the species the kinds of experience
of human experiences emotional
experiences that went along with doing
science and so ultimately I decided the
only way I could honor that commitment
was to write the book you capture your
experience in a really lyrical way in
the book and to give our listeners a
sense of it I wanted to read the first
page of your chapter titled the Sun wall
to the south of camp and just a bit east
stood a majestic rock wall it rose out
of the water
a massive buttress around which the
fjord jogged southeast for several miles
before continuing its eastward trend to
the inland ice cap it stood for nearly a
thousand feet above sea level and
dominated the world where we camped in
summer the Sun makes a lazy circuit in
the sky neither setting in the North
even at midnight nor rising more than 40
degrees above the southern horizon when
it reaches its Apogee at noon low Sun
angles make for striking shadows and
with the Sun orbiting the entire sky the
face and form of things never stay the
same
my tent opened to the west giving me a
view down many miles of open fjord water
but the rock wall was to my left and
behind me when I would emerge in the
morning from my tent I always turned
towards that massive to get a sense of
what the day's weather might be it was
of course no way to gauge how the day
would evolve high arctic weather is
notoriously mercurial but even so
somehow seeing that bulwark in the
morning light gave a perspective on the
day that would sit with me until we got
back to camp in the evening so I'm also
a scientist and I loved the book in how
it brought that emotional experience of
doing science not just getting the
results but also just being in the
process of doing the work to people who
may not be familiar with it and I'm
wondering if you've shown the book to
your colleagues and other scientists and
what their response is to this you know
not really traditional way of describing
science did they understand where you
were coming from absolutely and it's
been interesting for me to share this
book with colleagues all over the world
I've talked with other geologists people
who have been to wild places wilderness
areas all over the planet and it's been
fascinating to me the espanha that's
exactly what I want to do too I've tried
but it just hasn't worked out or it's so
badly needed this kind of thing and I
it's just been overwhelming actually to
to have the kind of response from other
scientists to this storytelling and I
think this sharing of experiences and I
think it speaks volumes to something
that many of us who were doing science
and it doesn't matter what kind of
science there is this emotional
component that we want to get out but we
have worked so hard to be objective and
rigorous and unemotional so that we can
unbiased ly convey what we do that we
suppress this other human side of the
experience do you think this lesson has
implications beyond just bringing the
beautiful experience of doing science
to the public as scientists as this
community of people spending their lives
gathering knowledge we are in danger of
losing our role in how society in
general changes over time because we are
not doing enough to engage with the
broader community of humanity I think
the political turmoil that exists around
the world in so many different ways
could be to some extent affected by
scientists becoming more engaged with
society and the reason I believe that is
that we live lionized to concentrate on
rationality on objectivity and being
wrong is what we're about all the time
and we know that we accept it
being able to show that being wrong or
uncertain is actually a beneficial way
of moving through this world could
benefit a lot of people who I think get
stuck in dogma and certainty when
there's so much uncertainty out there
well William glass Lee thanks very much
for joining us well thank you the book
is a wilder time notes from a geologist
at the edge of the Greenland ice by
William glass Lee and it's out this
month and that's it for February we'd
love to hear from you you can leave us a
comment on the science magazine books
blog books at all and we'll be back in
March with another book to add to your
stack and that concludes this edition of
the science podcast if you have any
comments or suggestions for the show
write to us at science podcast at AAAS
org you can subscribe to the show on
iTunes stitcher and many other places or
listen to us on the Science site at
science magic
Codd casts or you can also find links to
the research and news stories discussed
in each episode this show was produced
by Sarah Crespi and edited by Paula G
Jeff cook composed the music on behalf
of science magazine and its publisher
triple-a us thanks for joining us
[Music]